[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
i can go on about this company
for a long time jason i i have i've been
asking cumulus to get them as a sponsor
for years i have
a sonos device in every room of my house
and you know they've got the new rome
which is awesome which i'll talk about
but talk about you know the old days
where you have big receivers and
speakers and crap all over your house
you really don't need anything with
sonos you could have this little device
in each room a speaker that plays music
and i could play a different song in
each room of the house
i could play a party mode outside and
put on some nice chill sexy music
upstairs sonos man so sonos does it and
with the new rome it's the ultra
portable smart speaker that allows you
to bring the sonos experience everywhere
you go rome weighs less than a pound
it's premium durable design makes it
perfect for the home and for on the go
when you're home rome connects to your
wi-fi network and the rest of your sonos
system and then automatically pairs with
your phone on bluetooth when you're on
the go for a seamless
experience it's it's it's truly amazing
sonus has done it again
they are uh
they are one of the leaders in
technologically advanced companies i
would say is that is that correct oh for
sure my friend's dad actually worked for
sonos when we were kids really he was a
great engineer they've been around they
know what the hell they're doing the
sonos absolutely and you know they got
this thing used uh using automatic true
play
now true play rome smartly adapts to
your surroundings and whatever you're
listening to right it creates sound
that's astonishingly detailed and
perfectly balanced control rome using
the app apple airplay 2 or your voice
with amazon alexa or google assistant
with sonos you can start with one
speaker and expand your system over time
like i have done i have so many
different speakers across and they're
affordable and they last forever i have
the same stuff they sent me some new
stuff
and of course i use it but i have my old
stuff and it's been lasting me for years
and years all you guys got to do and
listen when i say this is a great
product and you're going to love it i
talk about it all the time go to
sonos.com that's it go to
n sonos
s dot com
learn more and if you could say that the
inside of you podcast brought you there
by all means do it
go to sonos.com you're listening to
inside of you with michael rosenbaum how
are you guys happy new year i i freaking
love that you're still listening to me
there's so many podcasts out there and
you choose to be here or maybe you're
here for zach levi and that's wonderful
too but maybe you'll like it and you'll
go hey this guy's not a complete schmuck
and listen to me uh it's important if
whether you're listening on spotify or
apple or whatever please write a review
of the podcast it helps the podcast
substantially so if you like it the
least you could do is maybe write a
review for me the old man here you know
happy new year to everybody i hope you
had a happy and safe uh holiday right
now with me ryan's in hawaii so
sitting in for him is our editor jason
nelkin is it nelkin right nelkin's
correct no that's correct how are you
bud i'm good how are you i'm good
thank you for editing the show i love
editing the show you do it's my pleasure
oh dude he's great he just came over
today i hadn't met him in person and he
came in my office i was showing him
around showing my toys i believe they
farted in front of you and you did i did
i apologize that's bad man
thanks man it's uh you know it's kind of
like built for a child a man child isn't
it that's how it should be that's how it
should be adults are just grown children
do you have a girlfriend i do have a
girlfriend you do i don't
so i know ryan does you do we know bryce
does
uh he's married and i'm solo
that's okay i'll find one yeah i
wouldn't be so hard on yourself about it
how old are you i'm 29. oh man you're
just a kid dog i could be your dad
yeah i'm 49. yeah you would have it
would have been some sort of uh you know
accident situation it should have been
an accident at that age accidents do
happen yeah um guys i love you thank you
we're gonna get to zach levine a second
but just uh make sure you follow us on
the instagram at insideepodcast and the
facebook at insideepodcast
and please follow us on twitter at
insideepod also you can go to the inline
online inside of you store uh you can
get uh smallville lunch boxes you can
get inside of you tumblers brand new
inside of you hats i got a new the old
script from smallville called lexmas
which is a lot of people's favorites you
can get one of those signed by me
tons of stuff on the inside of you
online store also you can go to
sunspin.com my band and get a zoom with
me and there's so much cool merch steven
amell and tom welling always wear my
sunspin hats and shirts and
i appreciate it so if you want to copy
them
feel free to do it uh also i can't uh
say enough about my patrons those guys
you know you guys if you don't know what
patreon is go to patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com slash inside of you this is a
group of people that give back to the
podcast they believe in it they love it
and without them i don't know what i do
so if you love the podcast and you want
to give back
you can give back anything it doesn't
matter it it helps substantially
and uh you know i love them i just did a
zoom with all the top tiers um you know
and we all zoomed together and talked
and got to see their faces that was cool
but it's become a real close family the
patron family i think
you know a lot of people have said god
i've made so many close friends through
this this patreon and um
it's cool it's cool there's so many
perks and things like that so check it
out patreon.com inside of you i'm also
on cameo um i want to say thank you
before we get right into the interview
with
those that supported echoesofhope.org
for foster youth those that supported
foodonfoot.org for the homeless
situation we have in los angeles and all
of the world
and uh
and the ronald mcdonald house if you
gave any money or if you thought about
them during the holidays i i really
appreciate it i know some of you did
and it makes me feel good it makes me
feel good that you guys are
supporting me and supporting all these
great charities
um
that's about it man uh new year's
resolution
uh it's been five days i'm not vaping
anymore uh i quit sodas no candy no like
no chocolates no chips at night
i'm trying to get in shape i'm trying to
be better to myself are you doing
anything for new year's resolution i
have no new year's resolution you have
none uh yeah i just uh you know i uh all
year i you know resolutions are for the
whole year for me well mine starts five
days ago and it's it's gonna hopefully
continue i'm gonna try and stay
i think you know with anxiety and things
like that if you cut out all the crap
and see where you're at when you cut out
all the crap you'll get a better idea
of who you are and how much better you
can feel by not doing all the crap does
that make sense definitely achieve
equilibrium
achieve equilibrium and then see where
you're at i like that achieve
equilibrium let's get inside of zach
levi it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience how are you my friend
oh man i'm i'm really good i'm i'm today
i'm a little i'm dragging a little ass
because i had a lot of fun and by fun i
mean tequila
at uh the premiere party last night for
american underdog that was just last
night so american underdog the kurt
warner story you play kurt warner i do
yeah and this premiered last night in
las vegas last night where mad chinese
and how much fun was it
it was super fun i mean
you know i mean
you you you you go and make a thing you
believe in it you hope that it all comes
together i've seen it i
i feel like it's all there you know i'm
proud of it we made it in the middle of
the pandemic and all the craziness and
um
and then you go and do all the work and
doing the press and and then it and then
it's here and then you're like okay well
i hope and it's not even really open
right so it's like you know we premiered
last night but it doesn't open until
christmas so right i still won't really
know what critics or people or whatever
think about it but right this will have
aired this will have aired by the time
yeah the movie will be out so if you're
listening to this folks i the movie's
out
the movie's out next out and hopefully
you've seen it and if you haven't please
go see it and if you do see it i hope
you enjoy it and if you don't enjoy it
then
if you no then uh no no i fuse no i mean
people are allowed to not enjoy things
yeah i enjoy it i was gonna go different
way with that joke i wasn't just gonna
like lambast people for not liking my
parents and if you don't like it if you
don't like it what
and then kick rocks then watch shazam no
i don't know then yeah then watch
there you go watch shazam um do you feel
like when you go to premiere because i
know i feel this way when i have a
premiere for something uh that's a
project that i've been working on
you're not getting a real
uh
real response a visceral
uh a real audience response because it's
all people that are there the studio
they're your family they're your friends
they're like you are great yeah yeah
that's what it felt like last night i
it's weird because i watched it i didn't
i actually didn't watch a screening last
night i went had some dinner i'd already
seen it and um but when i watched it
i i did i felt good about it i felt like
okay i felt good about what i did you
know normally we're our own worst
critics and so i think everybody is i
think artists particularly are that or
maybe i don't know maybe not maybe maybe
generally all people are are just as
much but as an actor being critical of
yourself you go and watch your
mug projected up on this massive screen
and first of all i have such a hard time
just not destroying myself
looking at just my face being like oh
you got bags under your eyes or this or
that or you know looking at my constant
incredible constantly picking up picking
myself apart from just the aesthetic of
how i stand and how i hold myself and
what i'm doing with my hands so you're
not even enjoying it you're so hard it's
so hard yeah so if you can get past that
would you get past it
i'm getting better at it i think i think
a lot of therapy and medication has
helped that i mean i'm not kidding yeah
yeah you know i've watched so many
things i've done and i
i just it's so hard for me to get to the
other side when i watched shazam for the
first time i
i genuinely thought people were going to
hate me in it i i couldn't why was that
i don't know because i was looking at
all my choices and things that i made as
an actor and in the character and
was like oh my god do i just look like a
big idiot am i just being a big idiot
and people are going to be like who is
this big dumb idiot you know right uh
fortunately that wasn't the case and it
worked out and you know but it also that
also taught me yet again like hey you
can't trust i mean we're going to dive
into so much mental health in this
anyway but just to change it into it
really quick it's like you can't trust
your own mind which is very terrifying
in some ways but also very comforting i
find you know because because we are i i
love this quote we are not the voice of
our mind we are the one who hears it
and and and that's the truth and it's
it's from the the um untethered soul
which i have yet to read but i've read
but you like the quote i love the quote
i love the quote i i i'm a horrible
reader i i i just don't get to books
nearly as much as i need is it just a
little add
oh certainly more than a little yeah but
oh i don't know also i think you know
coming up as a kid in the 80s like my
stories were video games i didn't like i
i like a good book i couldn't put when i
was in high school and i read a brave
new world i could not put it down it
wasn't a soap opera no
well no that's a song from aladdin oh
the uh yeah the bold and the beautiful
uh that's that's what i was thinking
right right
but you couldn't put that book down no
man and you know in a lot of other books
i just like i cliff notes that stuff
because i just couldn't stay in it but
brave the world like rocked me and we're
also kind of witnessing it happening in
the real world right now in some ways we
can get to that later
anyway so yeah man eviscerating myself
on screen all the time as an actor but
then
again you know i've grown a lot i've
done a lot of therapy we've talked about
a lot of that therapy we've talked about
medications before and that's been very
helpful and so you know watching
american underdog i was able to i think
get through some of that
weird you know criticisms and kind of
shut all those voices up enough to just
get see through all that and be like
i you know i didn't totally hate myself
it which then was a great it was like
which means that would be great
i must be
so i don't know i mean
i'm proud of it i i really do think we
made it uh a good little movie and it's
got so much
heart heart and and and hope i mean it
and faith and you know there's it's it's
a very inspiring story it's true story
kurt warner you know he was uh he was
this you know good old boy from iowa
always wanted to be the next joe montana
and then didn't get a lot of play in
college in
northern iowa uh university
but he got just enough where he got this
last minute you know a tryout with the
packers right out of college and
and he me he miffed it he just he
couldn't step up to that occasion it was
it was way too much for him in that
moment wow he was a great player but i
mean there's a lot you know he's
watching farv throw throw passes in
front of him you know as they're going
through like training camp he's like
what is this this is insane
so then that doesn't happen and then he
kind of just he goes and wanders in the
wilderness for a while he had met brenda
his now wife he wanders in the
wilderness he just takes away he goes
away from football well yes and no so
like in the in the midst of all this he
meets his now wife brenda and she's such
an integral part of their entire story
and you know uh
he
he in large part became the man that he
is the leader he is and the quarterback
that he was because of her love and her
faith in him and wow his love and her
faith in in her and
and her children she uh had two kids at
the time her oldest son zach and their
and her baby daughter jesse and he took
them on and he took them on as a 21 year
old you know college kid essentially
because he just he felt
he felt compelled yeah he felt this love
for them and he and this compulsion and
yeah absolutely and i think you know
very much god i mean their their journey
is so incredibly blessed in the ways
it's all kind of worked out but
ultimately you know she was this 24 year
old divorcee with two kids and her
oldest son or her her oldest who her son
zack he was dropped uh as a baby on his
head by her former husband and he ended
up having uh intellectual disabilities
and so she was quite a package you know
as a young mother and
and uh and i think you know partly
because kurt grew up also in a with a
single mom for you know a lot of his
life and he and his brother and so i
think that there was this you know that
that story was already kind of being
laid the groundwork was already being
laid a little bit in his heart and his
mind and and he could recognize that and
see that and it's amazing that he could
be that strong at 21. oh yeah because i
i'm 49 and i i you know trust me i can't
take on uh yeah i could barely take on a
dump in the morning yeah yeah we know um
but uh no yeah it blows my mind that he
you know he valued he saw value in that
he wanted to keep seeing how that road
went and then they kept falling deeper
in love his uh relationship with zach
right out of the gates i mean the first
day he goes to like basically surprise
brenda at he had just met her at a honky
tonk like at a bar doing line dancing
he's like i want to i want to hang out
with you and she's like you don't want
to hang out with me on 24 i got two kids
you know
and then he finds out where she lives
and she and he goes and just brought her
flowers and she was like in the middle
of something and her son zach opened the
door by the way intellectually disabled
also blind and he opens the door and he
loved radios he would listen to music
all the time and he opens the door and
kurt's there and he grabs kurt's hand i
mean
the the details in the movie versus what
actually happens in real life are very
very similar i'm not sure that we got
them you know to the point but
essentially
this little boy leads him into the house
and uh because he needs help with this
radio he needs his radio needs batteries
and he can't get anybody to help him
because his mom's getting ready to go to
school or work or whatever
and uh and he goes and gets kurt to go
find him batteries and puts batteries in
and then he like wants him to lay down
on the on the cool of the bath of the
bathroom floor just listen to music with
him
and like that really happened and it's
really in the script and i remember
getting to that point in the script and
i was like i've never
seen something so pure like that seems
like such a pure moment to have on a
screen and like the love that that
starts building and the love that he
starts building with brenda and anyway
their whole journey is amazing and then
ultimately
he yeah he wasn't playing football he
couldn't play football there was no
football to be played he was trying to
figure out how to get another shot in
the nfl um
they were super struggling you know
scraping change out of car doors to put
gas in their tank like that those types
of you know things that a lot of us can
relate to
going through some harsh iowa winters
and all that stuff and
so he started stocking shelves at a
grocery store yeah the hyvee and he did
that for i don't know six months to a
year or something and in the process of
that this arena football had started to
kind of pop up but he was he kept it out
on arm's length because he felt like and
i totally understand too i could totally
understand his mentality of feeling like
well that's
if i go do that then i'm giving up on
the real thing this is the this is the
jv so this is whatever it is but but i'm
you know what i mean like this is where
guys end up if they can't play nfl or
they're done with the nfl right and i
don't want to believe that
and you know i think there was just so
much interesting up and down and in both
he and brenda's journey and their
journey together um that there was a lot
of just you know i don't know humbling
almost in some respects right because he
gets to this point where he's like i
don't want to stock shelves anymore and
i can make better money and i get to do
a thing that i i really love doing that
gives me purpose which is to go have a
ball in my hand like football basketball
yeah he did it all but football
specifically
and uh and so you know he he gives in to
the uh to this guy who had the arena
team um the iowa barnstormers in in iowa
in the local arena team and he'd been
bugging kurt like come on you got to
come play for me he saw him play in
college or whatever knew he got a shot
with the packers but it didn't go
anywhere and kurt kept like no no no no
no no and then fine it's like okay fine
let's go i mean this is such a
compelling amazing story yeah it's
insane it's it's it's one of those
things where well hold on it gets better
well you know the story right you know
the end of it and all that jazz no
that's why i'm ready for the movie so
you know don't give it away i don't
really know the end of it i know he
makes the rams yes but you know what
happened with the rams well he ends up
winning the super bowl yes and he won
and all that
anyway so point is he goes and plays
arena and
in doing so he actually gets some looks
now again from the nfl
uh and
ultimately does get this opportunity
with the rams
and uh he he was a
you know his his first year in this in
the league he was like 27 very old
rookie you don't have rookies coming
into the nfl 27 27 i think yeah 27. and
then the next and he didn't play at all
20 and he was like a third backup
quarterback second season
second backup quarterback or something
like that i think he made it up to the
number two spot
trent green is their number one who was
a
very talented quarterback at the time
and everybody had a lot of high hopes
high hopes for him
and um um vermeel was her head coach he
it was like his kind of cinderella story
too because after
philadelphia he kind of went off and
into the his own wilderness and came
back and so he's head coaching mike
martz is the offensive coordinator who
has this incredible offense he's worked
out with all of these incredible tools
in this team and the rams like really
have a shot and then trent green and
preseason down injury uh in season
injury uh season ending injury wow and
that's how he got a shot well yeah but
here's the thing i mean the rams also
like
i'm sure they were calling around they
were like is there anybody because
you know this guy was still this
untested 28 year old now rookie we've
got kurt warner and we in the in our
pocket yeah let's get someone else
because
and look at the end of the day it was
kurt's because no one else was available
nobody else worked it was all and
they're like so dig for meal and there's
this yeah very famous
uh uh press conference because there was
a lot of heat also like the media was
like what are you there was all these
you know
um stories and things going on like espn
like who's this are they gonna you know
put the whole the weight of the team and
the and the season on this guy's
shoulders this guy who just came out of
the arena league and all that so there's
all that narrative going around and then
dick for me only he has this press
conference he goes we are going to rally
around kurt warner and we're going to
play good football i mean it's this
really great clip it is it almost seems
fictitious it does it does if you tell
us if you know when when this all
happened in real life when
then kurt steps in and then basically
leads the team as a 28 year old rookie
with very few snaps that he ever you
know he takes the team all the way to
the super bowl wins the super bowl he
wins mvp of both the season and the
super bowl and was making league minimum
when he did it like there were guys
league minimum what's league minimum i
don't know what it was back then it
wasn't a lot of money no but i but i
know that there are people in the
organizations the football organizations
that like
tend to the and by the way it's a very
big job tending to like the fields right
like the greensmen for like to they take
sure some of those people i believe i
heard it quoted some of those people
make more than what he was making as
league minimum so the guys that were you
know tending to the fields were like
cool this guy
who was this guy and what's he doing
inside of you is brought to you by
shopify shopify the all-in-one commerce
platform to start run and grow your
business i have it i have the inside of
you online store on shopify i love
shopify it's easy to use
and uh you know you make money off the
site they do the
everything for you like you know when
you're doing the shipping stuff with
shopify
it's like you press a button buy a label
but press the print this out it's so
easy man
i love shopify i don't know uh another
company that does this stuff i think
this is the they're the cream of the
crop jason the go-to they are
uh shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so upstarts startups and established
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed scaling
your business is a journey of endless
possibility believe me this podcast
started out selling um you know like a
t-shirt and i was like you know is this
going to work in in making you know a
little money and now today i've got tons
of products and
tons of customers
and it's all because of shopify they
they know what they're doing they made
your dreams come true they made some
dreams come true they're really helping
and i think people that order off
shopify and they go to the inside of you
online store they dig it and it's easy
to use and they're digging the product
and uh you know i pack this [ __ ] myself
too can i say [ __ ] i'm sure i can i
don't think they're going to worry
because i'm being passionate here
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and more gain insights as you grow with
detailed reporting of conversion rates
profit margins and beyond and i'll tell
you it's so cool to look at like oh wow
look how much better i'm doing than last
month oh look it gives you a little
you know four months ago i was doing
this what am i doing right now or what
am i doing wrong you could see what
products selling better it's so fun to
kind of navigate that and then start
getting products that you know work
it's like a game it's it's kind of like
a game
uh i really love shopify it's more than
a store check this out go to shopify
s-h-o-p-i-f-y
go to
shopify.com inside all lowercase
shopify.com inside for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com inside right now
shopify dot com slash inside inside of
you is brought to you by magic spoon ra
rice i called you ryan jason
ryan's usually here with me but jason's
here and jason you still eat cereal
i do you do and you know how bad most
cereals are for you the horrible
horrible you know how much sugar most
when we were kids you know i'm not we
can't say names but like you know things
that rhyme with
fruit floops
you know bucky darms yeah all those you
know things that just
are just you get these giant sugar
rushes and then you crash and they're
just bad for you when you get to be an
adult you're like man i miss those days
when i can have cereal
but it's so unhealthy that you can as an
adult but you can
you can do it now folks and i'm telling
you this is some delicious cereal this
is magic spoon look we're all trying to
eat better but healthy breakfast doesn't
have to be boring magic spoon has the
amazing flavors you love but without all
the bad stuff and it's amazing as a
midnight snack right before bed uh you
know new year's resolution i'm cutting
down on the carbs i'm cutting down on
the sugars and unhealthy food and uh you
know i i'm i'm eating some magic spoon
and it makes me feel good makes me feel
young i want to feel young like you
jason you're 29.
i want to feel like i'm 29 again man
check this out
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in each serving only 140 calories in a
serving keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low low-carb you don't
even know know the difference it tastes
so good build your own box available
flavors to build your very own custom
bundle are coco
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
cinnamon cookies and cream and maple
waffle my lord and you know my favorite
is peanut butter uh i like the fruity
and go figure i mean i'm a little fruity
here uh
it's easy guys please check these guys
out go to magic spoon
m-a-g-i-c-s-p-o-o-n.com magicspoon.com
iou grab a custom bundle of cereal and
start your new year off right and be
sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident
their product is back with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked i
love that i love when people do that
because i'm the guy that would go oh
yeah i want to return this
i don't think you're going to i think
you're going to like it remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt free
cereal at magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode inside of you is
brought to you by betterhelp boy uh i'll
tell you if it's one sponsor that i
could really relate to and uh not that i
don't relate to all the others i do but
better help online therapy uh i'll tell
you it's changing lives it's helping
people all across the world so many of
my friends are doing it using it ryan
you use betterhelp how's your therapy
going it's going very well yeah i feel
like you got a good therapist now and
you're uh you're happy i yeah i am i do
uh yeah it's great and you use it uh
at least every month yeah no uh once a
week once a week once a week i have a
video chat session and you know the uh
yeah the text chat is always open so if
there's any any issues
or uh someone's got a lesson for you
then yeah it's great so you just text
them
you know people think you should wait
until things are are unbearable to go to
therapy
and that's could that couldn't be
further from the truth therapy is a tool
to utilize before things get worse and
it can help you avoid those
lows
sometimes we just wait till everything's
just hit the fan and then we go i need
therapy
if you feel like you're starting to lose
a little control if you feel like you're
starting to
feel that depression anxiety you just
need someone else to talk to
someone objectively
better help online therapy folks many
people think therapy is for so-called
crazy people
but therapy doesn't mean something's
wrong with you it means you recognize
that all humans have emotions and we
need to learn to control them
not avoid them and we've been taught
that mental health shouldn't be a part
of normal life uh but that's wrong we
take care of our bodies with the gym
the doctor and nutrition we should be
focusing on our minds just as much and i
i
wholeheartedly agree
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to i like to see them so
does ryan
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
inside your listeners get 10
off
by going to
better
help
dot com slash inside that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot-com
slash inside do yourselves a favor
get some help
so things changed obviously after he won
the super bowl yeah well they they had a
day
hopefully yeah yeah i don't know i don't
know that you know you don't know that
part of it who knows who knows you know
but um
but at the end of the day it was just
this incredible thing we all happened
you know we were watching it happening
in real time i was i was 19 living in
ventura watching this
crazy [ __ ] go down like this is history
happening in our lifetime like what the
heck and then also because you know
being a person of faith and
he he being a person of faith there was
that spiritual kind of connection too
and even more inspiring in that regard
and uh so yeah and that was are you guys
close
i would say we're pretty close at this
point yeah was it was it weird in the
beginning because it's like i'm playing
you were you kind of like you know i
want to do you right man i'm you know
this is i'm only as good as this script
here i'm to give you guys some
personality what fears did you have
going into that i mean the fears that
look when we take on a fictitious
character there's nobody
that can really hold us well a real
character oh you're saying you're not
your example exactly exactly yeah
example no kurt is very fictitious he's
very he's a fake person he is a phony
man
um
so
so yeah um but yeah we take on a
fictitious character there's nobody
there's nothing to really hold us
accountable to some expectations
unless there's some canon like
you know i'm actually grateful like with
shazam i'm grateful that
shazam wasn't as well known a superhero
because if you go take on superman
batman wonder woman whatever everyone in
the world has an idea of what you're
supposed to do with that character i
don't envy any of the pressure that
cavill or any of our batman or
uh
brother affleck or or now you know gal
with wonder woman anything that's so
embarrassing iconic it's iconic it's
like there's a lot more shazam i got a
little more i think creative license
with it because there are also a couple
different well every superhero has a lot
of different iterations of them by this
point with all the different like
universes and multiverses and dimensions
and yada yada um
but i had some some real fun latitude in
that as as kurt as a real person who by
the way
you know this isn't like
this is not daniel day-lewis playing
abraham lincoln who's well dead and
there's no footage that you can hold up
right you know i think maybe i heard
once that there's maybe some crazy
recording of his voice a little bit you
can hear somewhere i don't know right
but there's no real you know content
that you can hold that person so like
you said you're not held accountable so
it's easier it's a little easier but
perhaps perhaps
by the way
daniel d lewis is a god among men when
it comes to acting and all his
incredible talent so i don't think
he could he'd crush it either way yeah i
just knew that stepping into being kurt
warner was definitely going to be this
thing where
you know there's going to be that extra
level of people going
i don't know kurt like that
do they look alike do they talk a like
do they act alike do they you know what
what is their what is it plus how many
footballs have you thrown
not many bro certainly not well i mean i
got like a two-month quarterback crash
course did you feel like you really
improved oh definitely for sure yeah
like you were like i could throw a
football how far can you throw a
football
um
i could throw pretty far football man 40
50 yards uh at least yeah i think i i'm
not at least but i mean yeah i think i
could i could hit that i think i was
throwing a 60 actually and relatively
accurate
sure but like i also had incredible
doubles right like i had one double we
have so many takes and so much football
to be played and all those throws need
to be dimes like perfect because the
camera is coordinated it's like it's
like so they don't use many of your
throws probably no no i think i actually
got quite a few in but
what i'm saying is that
i could throw 60 and i could hit that
but how consistently if you need that to
be the exact shot over and over and over
again right and you've got full ass men
grown ass men that are playing actual
real football on the field essentially
like they're really hitting each other
and tackling each other and
running full out so you know you want to
make sure that their everyone is
coordinated and everyone's getting the
best pieces they can get so you want to
have that guy who's your who's your
sniper who should be there to take care
of that and then also i had so i had
basically i had two doubles will and
deke and will was my you know kind of
more of my
physical double and and arm double deak
was
he was the truck man he got all the hits
like all the heavy heavy heavy like i
took some heads and i wanted to take
some hits because not that i'm super
method or whatever but i was like i
can't be a quarterback and never be
tackled and never like know what that
feels how does it feel it sucks of
course what do you mean i honestly the
the worst part about it was just like
i'm not used to the whiplash in my head
going back and hitting the uh and
hitting the ground and with the weight
of the helmet on so like the next day
after i you know hit that stiff heavy
stiff
why is my neck hurts so bad and then to
put it together because i'm wearing this
this weight on my head and then getting
snap back but whatever dude i it was so
fun it was so cool and and my hits were
like you know half hits quarter hits
whatever did kurt come up to you after
the movie was there a moment where he
said
thank you or
you did me right
i mean he yeah well he we all saw it
kind of separate we saw different um
early like screeners you know like he
was with his family in phoenix and they
got to see it and i got to see it i
think where i was in atlanta
and um yeah man and we've done a whole
bunch of press now together and we've
and they've asked that question like did
he do you right did he yeah yeah i think
look at the end of the day it all it all
did him and brenda and the and the kids
and the family right you know i think
obviously there's going to be some
people out there who are naysayers or
people saying oh it didn't go down
exactly like this or that or whatever
but they don't understand that this is
what the heart of the movie is we you
only got two hours to tell a story and
you can't put every story a life well
yeah well at least a part of life you
know it's like from you know him from 21
to 28 essentially right and they hired
this 40 year old
this 40 year old guy to go you know you
shave you put some makeup on you look
younger you know you dye the hair you
died it goes a long way i don't think
people were worried about it very long
people were worried about that no no no
no no it was it was fun though it was it
was a really incredible experience and i
learned a lot and i grew a lot and so
where can they watch this
well in theaters exclusively right now
in theaters yeah it's not a day in day
there's no streamer that i know i don't
know that there is one uh like what the
next window is going to be i think
lionsgate just really wanted to commit
to doing like it's a christmas day
proper theatrical release and
you know we'll see how
the variants of the oh micron all the oh
my crap oh my kron uh but movies like
this do well you look at movies like
invincible with marky mark
wahlberg and i mean the movie did really
well football movies tend to do well
well true true true stories true stories
in general truths
stories and true sports
underdog stories you know these
cinderella stories they're all great and
they tend to be you know
first of all they're great just because
your source material is so already
inspiring right it's like this every
people even know the story and they
still want to watch the movie yeah you
know what i mean it's like you want to
so so there's that but then you know
fortunately a lot of these movies and i
and i think ours included have been
crafted by really you know talented
people and leaders and a collective of
of talent that you know makes something
that's special you know on break no it
wasn't unbreakable what was it called
invincible invincible invincible was a
well-made movie yeah hoosiers is a
well-made movie yeah you know um
remember
remember the titans yeah you know so
you've got great ingredients but then
you've got great cooks that you know
then putting that all together because
i'm sure that there's some other like
true stories that are like that that
wasn't so compelling i don't know yeah
but yeah yeah well how's your stress
levels like because
you know you're
we talked before and it always feels
like you know you need to be working you
need to be working and you you were
working on being okay when you weren't
working and that was a big part of you
but how is it when you're like
jumping from like i talked to you and
you're like i'm like when are you in
town again you're like well dude i'm in
town right now so i'm like we'll get
your ass over here because you're going
to be going to shoot something else i go
are you not done with shimmy's like no
i'm done with shazam i'm done with the
football movie i'm i'm done but you're
on on on you're on to the next thing you
just don't like you're not a guy that
just wants to sit around for too long no
it can't happen
well so what are you working on in terms
of you not you not not work because
we'll get to that but like yeah no like
they're talking about personally
personally how are you how are you
feeling how are you when you get a role
like this how are you doing shazam how
are you taking care of yourself kind of
a broad question yeah but no a great
question uh multiple questions in one
um
i mean in this exact moment i'm
you know pretty groovy man honestly
i
i feel very loved
and then that starts with my own ability
to love myself like i feel like you're
really doing that
practicing it as best i can man
absolutely i think it's it all has to
start there
everything really i and we can we'll
dive down into that too but sure it's
it's got to be it's it's you know one of
the greatest analogies or metaphors i've
ever heard for it it just stands up so
well it's like you know you're losing if
the cabin pressure drops in the plane
and the masks drop
you put yours on first you have got to
put yours on first because
if you start trying to help other people
you're gone you're out right and you
might not even get to them and another
you know you've got to you've got to
handle your business
and part of handling your business and
taking care of your [ __ ] is really
genuinely understanding that you are
infinitely lovable it doesn't matter
what the [ __ ] you do it doesn't matter
what you succeed in or accomplish or
don't accomplish or anything else you
exist
you are therefore you are loved
end of story and and i i put my faith in
that because that's i really believe
that there is a god and i really believe
that that is god's
commitment to an agreement with us who
are extensions of god extensions of
god's light and love you know so
whoo
yeah and you're yeah so so i feel like
you got a little emotional yeah you know
but but so but i feel like i can really
believe that it does start there it does
start with us loving ourselves not by
the way not like
i think there's a lot of um insta
therapy like and by instant therapy like
instagram and by the way i i post things
all the time that i try to watch them
yeah yeah oh no not just those but like
um you know uh uh uh like i don't know
other people's memes or things or quotes
or you know you know inspirational
things yeah well or sometimes yeah
they're just specifically about therapy
and taking care of your stuff but
insta therapy like instant therapy
can i think lead a lot of people into
confusing self-love with narcissism
which is unfortunate and you know and i
also don't i think the word narcissist
gets thrown around far too much as well
and also
everyone has at least a touch of
narcissism in them like we are capable
of all the things we do all the things
even with all the work that we do there
are still you know these whatever these
little inklings these
whatever the in with within our human
being soul and our unhealed traumas or
whatever they are everybody can struggle
with this [ __ ] and everybody does some
people just struggle way harder in
certain areas on that mental health
spectrum right and we have to have grace
with all of that stuff as well but i
just want to
clarify that you know self-love
can be and we need to be careful about
not confusing it with you know just
being more self-centered and like
none of my problems are my problem i'm
loving myself and my problems mean
therefore other people are the reason
why i have problems you can love
yourself and hold yourself [ __ ]
accountable at the same time right and
you need to do that we all need to do
that we
how do i be how can i be a better person
how can i do things better how can i
light myself more by doing things that
are altruistic
but also but that also requires
first and foremost being aware enough
that you're unaware
and that's tough for folks until you've
really been humbled enough in life you
still think that you got it i got it i'm
aware
i'm woke i'm whatever it is yeah but we
need to be awake we actually need to
wake the [ __ ] up we need to wake up how
do we wake up i mean
by starting starting with loving
ourselves starting with recognizing that
we don't
that we don't and i know you didn't for
a long long time i didn't for 37 years
of my and even in the last you know four
years i've still struggled with it i
only found out four years ago that i
barely even liked myself let alone love
myself so i'm kind of dealing with yeah
exactly starting to start to like
yourself saying hey yeah hey this is a
good quality recognize that you have
some good in you there's a lot of good
in you and what's the things you don't
like well let's work on those let's not
and forgiving yourself of those things
see that's that's one of the biggest
problems that we have right now we don't
forgive we don't forgive ourselves and
we don't forgive each other we have no
grace for ourselves and each other and
you don't and it's this recipe
reciprocal kind of uh um symbiotic thing
you will not have grace for yourself if
you do not have grace for others because
if you're not practicing it with other
people you won't even be able to
identify what that means with yourself
and vice versa if you're not practicing
grace with yourself
and really understanding what that means
to give yourself some [ __ ] slack
cut yourself some slap get give yourself
a break
love yourself and go hey you're doing
the best with the tools that you were
given up to this point in your life
that's what you're doing i agree but i i
do think that sometimes we do things
that we hate about ourselves
and we repeat those things yeah and we
do them over and over and then we feel
like you know what you've keep doing
this yeah you keep doing these and why
and you don't deserve love you don't
deserve and that's because you're
punishing yourself michael that's the
lie
i know that's the lie that's the lie
god
is love and love has nothing to do with
that shame
what if you don't believe in god well i
think the uni then the universe energy
uh uh karma source energy karma all that
stuff's tied into that sure yeah
whatever dude i have no idea look
i have i have a lot of you know journey
as a christian in my life and my faith
is still very much tied to
a lot of the bedrock of
christ and his words and i think so many
of the things that he stood for um but i
would never ever be able to tell you
with any certainty at all that i know
who and what the entirety of god is
anyone who's selling you that i think
really needs to take a hard look at
their own hubris right i think it is
ridiculous as human beings that within
one sentence within one breath we can
both say
there is a god and i know everything
about them right
if there's a god you know [ __ ]
nothing
god is everything and everywhere we
can't possibly know all that right so i
think everybody needs to check
themselves on that level a little bit
you know let's let's still dive into our
spiritualities and go find as much of
god as we can and i think it's evidenced
all over you know the torah uh the the
new and old testaments the um even the
koran you can find really truly
evidenced
places where there is
i think recognition of this incredible
entity
buddhists hindu
there's all a recognition of guys we're
not doing this alone this there is there
is something that is way bigger than all
of us and we need to be humble to it
right you know and you're saying that
god has helped you in in most of that of
learning to love yourself for you
well because a lot of people there's
some people that don't believe in god
and like
i'm not
religious though right i think i'm kind
of spiritual but for people who are
sitting there going well i'm so glad
that zach found god but i haven't found
god but is it if it's not god that what
do i do for myself i understand and what
i'm saying and that's why i said earlier
i'm grateful for
the faith that i have and ultimately
what i truly do believe because i'm able
to pin
my
need desire and power of self-love onto
a concrete
foundation of actual love which is god
which is god so because i
because i believe even in the most
abstract
anybody can believe in the most abstract
form of god and still believe that
because there is that you can you can
you can say okay i believe that then i
can i believe that i'm worthy of love
what you're asking which i totally
understand is well if you don't have
that
how can you then still found where is
the foundation for you to say i am
absolutely
unequivocably uh uh worthy of love just
by being and what i would say to those
people who are listening out there
watching or
or or whatever is you're still a goddamn
miracle man you're still a miracle even
if this is all some random you're here
you're here
if this is all some random thing that
just happened to blow up is in this big
bang or what you know whatever that is
and we've evolved doing all of these
things which by the way i i actually
think that the story is
a lot of all of that i i'm not a
christian who believes there is no
evolution i think i go why the hell not
okay god's god if god wants to like do
things and evolve animals along the way
to make all the things that god wants to
make rock and roll you know right like i
don't know there's also like christians
i know that are like you know super like
oh i don't know astrology i go i don't
know who's to say that god didn't do all
of the things and also like made this
whole universe to in at least in part b
this cool celestial clock that makes us
all different in cool ways like who are
you to say what god is doing with
whatever god wants to do but what i like
about what you just said but you if you
rewind just a little you said you're
[ __ ] you're here you're here you're a
miracle so you're a miracle regardless
you're a miracle of whether you're a
miracle or not even regardless you're
here no you're well so you're even on
this
that's still a miracle
no no no no no mike no hear me out
you can be a miracle and connect that to
some spirituality you're also just a
scientific miracle the odds of you
existing the odds of this planet doing
what it's doing and that all of us all
of our individual spirits and energies
whether that's an energy that's
connected to each other or a bigger
thing or it's an energy that's just
exclusively within you you have actual
energy
glucose and all that [ __ ] flying through
your body the coffee that we're drinking
the sunshine that we're feeling that's
all real energy that's all real science
and that's all a [ __ ] miracle this is
a miracle place so you can either decide
i am worthy of love because i was
created
intentionally by an incredible artist
and architect or
i'm a miracle and i'm worthy of being
loved because i've [ __ ] made the lot
look guys lottery hey right my life
force happens to exist right now just
randomly whoa that's crazy yeah but also
the fact that
you're here and while you're here
if we only have one life
why not make the most of it and why not
at the same time why not try to accept
who you are
and appreciate who you are and just
become a better person certainly then
that's how you're going to learn if you
don't make changes in your life
to me you're never going to love
yourself if you don't love yourself now
if you don't make changes if you're
doing the same thing you know that whole
thing that if you repeat something
that's not working is insanity yeah yeah
doing the same thing over and over again
right right expecting a different result
exactly i think that you know you have
to do something and what that can do to
learn to love yourself is altruism to to
be helping other people to
to being a good person to being the best
person that you can be certain and
you're right but forgiving yourself
with you yeah you have got to you got to
radically
love yourself
radically man like that's accepting
everything accepting that you are
exactly where you are and that's okay
radically accept that the life that
you've lived up to this point you did
the best that you [ __ ] could
you have to we have to do this we have
to radically love ourselves a lot of
people will say i didn't do the best i
could i could have done better no
and i would say no because you haven't
because you haven't and that's okay and
you haven't not because you're a bad
person but because you literally have
synapses in your brain that were
programmed
completely unbeknownst to you or your
parents or any generations prior to this
we're just now learning right now how
our behaviors are so unbelievably wired
into our
our minds our our our bodies from by the
way also generational stuff that even
predates even the na the nurture just
nature stuff that's in our dna and we
science is is showing us all this stuff
which is even more reason to give
yourself a break
we are not we do not
we
our i mean gosh our minds alone the way
that our minds can get so hijacked by
just little bits of hormone changes in
our bodies and we and we think that
we're absolutely operating at our
highest ability to do the best that we
can all the time give me a [ __ ] break
no we're not give yourself a break you
were doing the best if you were abused
as a child and you've got all this
unhealed trauma in you
chances are you're going to do a lot of
[ __ ] that you
aren't proud of or
whatever you're still doing it and guess
what it doesn't
this does not by the way this is not a
license to go do stupid [ __ ] or things
that are hurtful to yourself or other
people we have got there is still
accountability that people need to
understand that sure you know
but we can hold people accountable we
can hold ourselves accountable and hold
others accountable without dehumanizing
them in the process
we dehumanize ourselves
we in our subconscious and the way that
we talk to ourselves our self-talk that
we learn from our parents my mom and
step dad were harsh in the way that they
talked to me i know they also loved me
in the best way that they could i've
gone to enough therapy to recognize that
they were [ __ ] up because they were
[ __ ] up by their parents
and it's this generation
down yes because you have to because you
have to it's because unforgiveness
because unforgiveness is not about them
anyway unforgiveness is like drinking
poison hoping that the other person's
going to die you're holding on to this
thing that's just festering in you and
killing you it's darkness and it's a lie
and and yes
you you are therefore not being able to
even practice the best self-love on
yourself because
you're hung up on this person and your
inability to love them
and i'm not understanding or
your feeling of their inability to not
love you if that makes sense
sure does that make sense i think so
yeah in other words in other words their
inability to love you like you can't
control things there's certain things we
just can't control 100 again that's but
again that's all part of the radical
acceptance of it all right it's like
that's one of the first i forgive you
you'll never understand me you'll never
be the mother or father that i want but
i love you and then that and that but it
can also have boundaries right you know
that's this is again one of the big
weird things that i think human beings
don't understand
like you can both
absolutely love someone and absolutely
not want to hang around them ever yes or
have anything to do with that i
understand or like the way that they
handle themselves in their life right
love is not just amplified graduated
like like and love are two very
different things i always feel like
feeling in love feels like a high like
which but but again feeling in love and
actual practice love are two very
different things and i think that's
important for everyone to understand for
myriad reasons not the least of which
having healthy romantic relationships
but even how you handle your family your
friends how you handle yourself do you
set your boundaries for yourself can you
love someone and not like someone yes
that's what i'm saying i mean i mean
honestly like really dislike someone 100
i have 100 where i'm like called to i
told my mother once i said mom
i love you
but i don't like you
i don't like you i would never hang out
with you if you weren't my mother
what was the context of this
conversation were you having a fight
no i think you had to get get all down
into it i think it was just it was just
more of an honesty like you know i don't
like the way you act i don't like the
way you treat you've treated me or
behaved i don't like all these certain
things but i do love you and i do
forgive you and you're my mother
but i i don't necessarily like you
there was there was a wrestler i don't
know i'm saying this but it just makes
me laugh because we're getting serious
but there's a wrestler and his name is
brother love
and brother you brother love used to
look at hulk hogan and say hulk hogan
i love
you
but that don't mean i
lie
[Laughter]
well yeah there you go i mean that's
something to be said about that things
we learned from the wwf
inside of you is brought to you by geico
jason
you own your own home not yet you rent
it
i do well it's not easy paying mortgage
and stuff is it no it's not i mean
that's usually the hardest thing for
anybody especially living in you know
cities or whatever
paying their rent huge hassle yeah it's
hard work but you know it's not hard
work you know it's easy i think i do
what is it i think it might be geico
geico's bundling policies the bundling
polls that's absolutely right it's easy
because you know
a lot of times you have to pay bills to
so many different people and it's a real
pain in the ass and geico
you could bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance along with your auto
policies you get the great rate and you
pay them both to the same place and
you're not dealing with all the crap
doesn't that sound good that's huge
that's huge
we're busy in our lives we don't we
don't have time i don't like to go to
the grocery store i get an app and they
deliver it
you know i don't want to pay 15
different people i want to pay geico i
want to deal with that more time for fun
exactly less time for tasks so what do
you do you just go to geico.com you get
a quote it takes very little time and
see how much you can save it's it's
geico easy visit
geico.com today
that's
even a rosenbaum can do it inside of you
is brought to you by sonos i can go on
about this company
for a long time jason i i have i've been
asking cumulus to get them as a sponsor
for years i have
a sonos device in every room of my house
and you know they've got the new rome
which is awesome which i'll talk about
but talk about you know the old days
where you have big receivers and
speakers and crap all over your house
you really don't need anything with
sonos you could have this little device
in each room a speaker that plays music
and i could play a different song in
each room of the house i could play a
party mode outside and put on some nice
chill sexy music upstairs sonos man so
sonos does it and with the new rome it's
the ultra portable smart speaker that
allows you to bring the sonos experience
everywhere you go
rome weighs less than a pound it's
premium durable design makes it perfect
for the home and for on the go when
you're home rome connects to your wi-fi
network and the rest of your sonos
system and then automatically pairs with
your phone on bluetooth when you're on
the go for a seamless
experience it's it's it's truly amazing
sonos has done it again they are uh they
are one of the leaders in
technologically advanced companies i
would say is that is that correct oh for
sure my friend's dad actually worked for
sonos when we were kids really he was a
great engineer they've been around they
know what the hell they're doing the
sonos absolutely and you know they got
this thing used uh using automatic true
play now true play rome smartly adapts
to your surroundings and whatever you're
listening to right it creates sound
that's astonishingly detailed and
perfectly balanced control rome using
the app apple airplay 2 or your voice
with amazon alexa or google assistant
with sonos you can start with one
speaker and expand your system over time
like i have done i have so many
different speakers across and they're
affordable and they last forever i have
the same stuff they sent me some new
stuff
and of course i use it but i have my old
stuff and it's been lasting me for years
and years all you guys got to do and
listen when i say this is a great
product and you're going to love it i
talk about it all the time go to
sonos.com that's it go to sonos
s-o-n-o-s
dot-com
learn more and if you could say that the
inside of you podcast brought you there
by all means do it go to sonos.com
by the way ryan do you love yourself
yeah sure
you do
sure you didn't even hesitate why is
that why do you love yourself what's the
first thing you can think of when you
when you say that
jesus man
uh
i don't know
you love yourself why why you think
you're a good person
i think i do okay i think i'm a good
person i think i i care about people um
i
uh i love i know what i'm good at and i
love the things when i when i do
good i love that i can do it well
okay that's fair yeah that's fair i
think
by the way zack what do you do
so what are some of the exercises you do
like even today that you have instilled
like do you wake up do you say your
gratitude's every day do you pray every
day do you no
you don't
i mean some sometimes i do i actually um
just listen to this really incredible
uh podcast uh this guy named andrew
huberman who's like this awesome
very intelligent uh scientist out of
stanford i think
like
neurobiology ophthalmology anyway
i learned so much from podcasts like him
when it comes to like hormones stuff
like serotonins and dopamines and how
the body works basically like
um
and he had this really interesting
podcast recently about gratitude and how
incredibly powerful gratitude is in our
lives
but also how
the gratitude practices that most people
have been doing
kind of you know writing down what am i
grateful for or five things you're
grateful for
they've done laboratory studies that
type of gratitude practice has
maybe some positive effect but not
nearly the effect that they've
discovered which was
if you are even told a story or see
something go and go down in front of you
or
tell a story yourself
to yourself
of like essentially literally a story
like a little narrative of like you know
um i or if you saw if you saw uh an old
lady you know trying to cross uh the
streets acts of kindness
but not even necessarily acts of
kindness although i think they're always
kind of intrinsically tied to
the gratitude someone shows someone else
so if you watch someone be grateful and
they and say thank you and you see see
gratitude happening and so yes if you go
involve yourself and be a real in
gratitude seeing gratitude being felt
absorbing
yeah well absorbing but essentially
witnessing it you know like that you're
that you're witnessing it somehow
for instance on instagram you see
somebody like uh saving a dog what's on
the dog tracks and the trains come and
the guy runs out of nowhere risks his
life yeah and says oh my god well no no
but again it's not the act of kind it's
like watching that dog
jump all over that person like thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
that is what does it watching again it's
an old lady trying to cross the street
and and you know traffic and stuff and
she has some bags these guys come up
like hey we'll help you help her get
across the street make sure the traffic
doesn't hit her get her to her car
that's all great and again the more you
associate yourself in those types of
situations as we all should we should
all be helping each other all the time
as much as we can right right so the
more we act in these acts of kindness
then therefore the more opportunity
there will be for grateful displays of
gratitude and the more other people
including ourselves can see these
displays happening the more deep our own
gratitude practice becomes and the more
positive effect it has on our body on a
literally a physiological level bro it
is mind-blowing so i would highly
recommend that everyone should go listen
to this yeah andrew huberman he talks
about uh gratitude practices so if
you're gonna listen to another podcast
come check it out come come back
come back
but listen yeah anyway so so so that's
the long way around of saying you know
what my my daily uh
my daily practice
man it's it's evolved so much
you know depending on where i was in my
life and where i felt my mental or
emotional spiritual or physical
well-being are at any moment in my life
and right now
i feel very stable i feel very solid i
feel i feel very connected to god
uh throughout the day because i try to
be very cognizant of the fact that god
is everywhere all the time and
uh very much a part of my life and
everyone else's and you can recognize
that in nature and each other and
opportunities and you know i mean i'm
reminded of god literally every time i
go and do a
a a promotional thing for american
underdog the fact that i even got to do
american underdog was completely faded
like i felt god's you know i use the
term god's fingerprints i thought god's
fingerprints were all over it i wasn't
even supposed to do that movie that i
was going to be available for it they
were i was going to be shooting other
stuff and they were going to be making
that and then the pandemic and then
everything got wiped and then all of a
sudden i was available they all wanted
to spool it up they were like you were
one of our first choices would you want
to do this read the script already knew
the story i was like this is incredible
let's go make this movie and it also
helped you know genuinely like going
back to the beginning of the
conversation
work work work work work and i have had
a hard time
sitting in that pandemic i had a real
hard time sitting in that my mental
health went
way down the drain again and i call you
i'm like yeah hey what are you taking
right now does it work and we talk about
like different things we're taking and
trying to get the right concoction or
the right recipe to to help us a little
bit for the things that we're doing 100
so
i thinking my mental health was much
stronger and then not and then sitting
and not working and not and it's not
even my fault right so like if i wasn't
working because i wasn't booking things
or auditions or whatever you can kind of
be like it's on me so then i can then
you can rationalize blaming yourself
almost right but i'm sitting there
feeling like i'm failing my life
because of nothing i did but just
because of a thing that happened and i'm
not working and i'm not doing the thing
that again i was deriving so much of my
identity and worth out of which was not
good and a good check to me that
recognized that that was a whole bunch
of work that i still had yet to do and
still continue to do right obviously but
coming out of that going into making
these
really
amazing little films in american
underdog in this other one unbreakable
boy back to back in oklahoma city and
finally for the first time
having enough friends and my therapist
convinced me like yo
you should try some
help some medical like some
pharmaceutical help it it it could
really help you to get just get out of
this the darkness and the fog that you
find yourself in when you hit these
deaths
and uh you know my therapist
um
who uh here in l.a who i um see when i'm
in la or still you know we'll do zoom
appointments here and there but he you
know i was talking to him and he's like
listen
you know
imagine you're in a
pitch black room i'm sure i've even
talked to you about this but imagine
you're in a pitch black room you know
that there's a light above you and a
switch right on that light and there and
you know there's a stool right next you
can feel it right and you know that if
you get on that stool you'll be tall
enough to reach the light and turn it on
but you need the stool to do it
think of it like that think of if you
need to go and get on some help with
some you know antidepressant or whatever
think of it as this stool you need it
for right now to turn that light on to
get your head above the darkness and
look around me oh oh some perspective
when you're
we have no perspective when we are in
super deep depression or anxiety another
another therapist i i once told me
another great analogy it's like imagine
putting put your hand all the way up to
your face and you're like well you know
what does that look like a hand well not
really it's all blurry and you see like
you know 20 different fingers you know
what i it's like can you identify
exactly what it is no if anything's this
close to your face you can't identify
what it is you just have to pull it back
a little bit you go oh that's my hand
and that's another kind of
analogy if you will about you just you
need to get that perspective and if
you're still stuck in depression
hardcore depression you have very little
perspective and well you have
perspective it's just completely [ __ ]
right that's that's where the lies can
really get to you that's why you you
start believing you start believing
things that are not real and that again
like understanding just how much our
bodies can be hijacked have grace with
yourself if you're stuck guys if you're
listening or watching this right now if
you are stuck in a darkness right now
have grace with you your mind is not
working the way it is supposed to work
your serotonin levels are down your
dopamine levels are down your nerve
epinephrine levels are down whatever is
down that can be that can be balanced
that can be helped that can be helped
through
through therapy talk therapy all manner
of different therapies it can also be
helped through psychiatry and getting
some type of medicine that can help
stabilize you so you can help
feel and see yourself and the world and
how you fit in it more clearly have a
semblance of normalcy in your life and
also you know what i will say about that
is like it it takes time you know i've
been going through some different meds
because you know my body reacts
differently yeah and so you know i the
last thing i was on i just was
constantly fatigued i felt like a zombie
yeah and i'm like all right well that's
not the you know you can't let it get
the best to you i'm like all right
what's the next thing yeah let's see if
there's something else that
i i can work with that's just you know
uh so i think that that that is is
important to know too it doesn't happen
the first time like oh i got on mads and
this no no this is terrible yeah no
because you know it's like yeah you've
changed math no when i when i finally
yeah when my when i was finally
when i finally let go of whatever the
fears of the stigmas of like being a
person who needed uh you know medication
to help him
emotionally mentally stabilize
you know this i've been talking about
mental health for years and i i all i
want to do is destigmatize it and yet
even for somebody who talks about it i
still feel those stigmas and those fears
we all do you know particularly when you
have poor mental health you're not
thinking clearly you're not seeing
clearly you're not feeling clearly so
those stigmas and fears become giants
instead of just being like no what am i
talking about that's ridiculous that's
not at all because there are so many
people that require this assistance and
by the way something my therapist told
me goes listen
once you're on the stool and you turn on
the light and you look around
maybe you don't need to stand on that
stool anymore maybe you're able to step
back and step down and the light stays
on and you're good and you're good and
and but furthermore and also maybe zach
maybe you need to stay on that stool for
a long time or forever who knows because
it you can't be judging yourself for
that and this why why
do does a diabetic
judge themselves because they have to
say insulin for the rest of their lives
i mean maybe if there's diabetes brought
onto themselves or maybe some people
feel you know a self
shame in that or self deprecation or
whatever but if you're born with
diabetes and you need insulin for the
rest of your life that's your life
are you sure should you judge yourself
and shame yourself because that's how
you were you're built that's your dna
absolutely not right and you know and
mental health is like dental health man
it should be treated the same we get
these little cavities of stresses and
anxieties and depressions and
lacks of self-love or value or whatever
it is these little little teeny mental
cavities and we don't do the work to
eradicate them when they're little right
and then they rot and fester and rotten
pheasants become full-on needed root
canals later on but still fixable still
fixable you can still get there you can
still do it you know good analogy on
that one yeah cheers i mean i think
about it that analogy that's really good
at any rate you know in therapy and
meditation and prayer and
and and medication all these things
these are ways for us to blush blush
brush and floss our minds you know and
and talking these things out and so
anyway going up into oklahoma to go do
these these incredible films that were
really life-changing i was now going on
to medication really for the first time
in my life and so yeah i started on
prozac and that really it did help me um
that's an ssri that's more of a
serotonin you know kind of um
uh powered situation what is this ss rea
and this is the serotonin reuptake
inhibitor but i can't remember the the
first s
anyway anyway most most antidepressants
um
that i know of i'm not an ex
an expert or authority on this but
most that i know of are ssris they are
serotonin-focused
um antidepressants but there are others
like wellbutrin which is what i
ultimately you know switch to which is a
um
that that's kind of focused on more of a
dopamine release is dopamine it's one of
the only drugs that releases i think i
think or one of the only antidepressants
antidepressants but again
i don't know
we're not we're not giving anybody
medical advice oh and but since we are
talking about this i but i would
encourage everyone out there if you are
struggling with a consistent depression
or anxiety
please do not hesitate in trying to get
some medical help there is nothing wrong
with it there is no stigma about it and
i'm telling you i am living proof that
you know i feared it i felt i feared the
stigma and i thought oh it's not going
to work or it's going to make me a
different person or whatever and i am so
grateful that i made that decision and i
but i'm also not suggesting that
everyone go try prozac
these are all very different experiences
for very different people so please
contact if you if you do feel like you
need it go get it i encourage you with
everything in my heart please go go get
that assistance if you need it but talk
to a psychiatrist yes a licensed
professional tell them what's going on
yes and be patient with it because as as
mike was saying
you know sometimes it doesn't work right
out of the gate first of all it takes
about a month to even really kick in
with a lot of antidepressants so you got
to give it time and in that time like
when i started on prozac so one of the
reasons i was having you know a lot of
anxiety
and anxiety and tax attacks and things
that would then also kind of tie into my
depressions and all these things and so
um some ssris are also very good at you
know helping to cycle down your
anxieties and then therefore helping
with the depression so i believe prozac
is is known to to do that so i was
taking that but you know with
with a lot of uh pharmaceuticals some of
the side effects are the very things
that you're trying to battle so like
with prozac you can get you can get like
a higher anxiety i was already having
high anxiety and then i started getting
some really high anxiety and it was
gnarly but you gotta
you gotta be very patient give it time
you know be in a space where you can do
it and have the people around you but
also remind yourself as my therapist
reminded me he goes you have to tell
yourself this is just your brain
remember this is your brain you are not
there's nothing to actually be anxious
about this is this is a great reminder
of how your body can hijack your mind
and you're like oh my god i'm on pins
and needles i've got so much anxiety
it's like no i'm not there's nothing
wrong in my life right now it's this
thing that is essentially affecting my
body and the way that it's affecting it
you are you know biohacking it right
and so then on the other side of the
anxiety that that did dwindle and then i
was in a much calmer state of the
serotonin you know reuptake um in
in inhibition i don't know um
uh and i and i felt much
better much
more stable uh calmer but more lethargic
type more tired libido was all messed up
like all you know things that you know
there are these other things that
sometimes you know are not what you want
but but ultimately it got me out of the
darkness enough where then i could start
actually thinking much more uh
critically much more um
uh
i could see reality
with more perspective sure and then in
that and diving deeper into now all of
you know these these these uh you know
huberman podcasts and things and
learning more about my body and how it
works um i became uh much more aware of
what i think was going on in my life
which was a massive dopamine deficiency
so
that's why i thought maybe i should go
and try
yeah and and sure enough man like
it i just
i think it's like what you ultimately
hope for with something like this which
is that you don't feel anything other
than normal
and i feel kind of normal
the most normal i've maybe ever felt in
my life for the first time in my life at
41 yeah yeah because i didn't realize
just how much
anxiety depression
i was suffering through my whole life
man like until i didn't know
that this constant
which turned out to be anxiety this
constant feeling in me of being like
walking on eggshells which was no
shocker i mean that was my childhood was
very much like that so it builds those
patterns in you you are your mind those
synapses are created and then all of a
sudden you live a life that is
accustomed to how you survived as a
child in your household and in your
community
that's an ego guys that that's how that
works
it's a it's an incredible like
safety device life raft
uh uh um suit of armor that we get but
it but it's not the end all because then
you at the end if you don't go actually
work on the traumas that you suffered
that your ego allowed you to suffer
through and survive if you don't go work
on that then you end up this crippled
contorted this you know
this this um
uh armor is now crinkled up on you and
crunching you in and you know you think
you're walking around and you're fine
but you're really all messed up inside
yeah because all of these you know hits
and and yeah
and uh so
anyway i i think that uh i think diving
into all of that stuff and recognizing
that more and recognizing what i i
really believe was in my childhood and
in my traumas i was constantly going
toward
addiction really i mean dopamine is uh
you get dopamine from almost any
addiction and i
didn't realize that like my video game
playing as a kid which was extensive and
still i play games now
like i i always you know you you always
kind of know like yeah i guess i was you
know
guess i was a gamer well no no meaning
like uh yeah certainly a gamer but no i
guess i was you know running there to
get away from my problems or whatever
but what you don't realize is that
you're not just distracting yourself
you're actually addicting yourself to a
thing and by the way that can be so many
different things right i mean
drinking sex drinking sex drugs all that
stuff but also like you know compulsive
uh buying like there's a lot of
collectors you know a lot of people that
love collecting things and guess what
part part of the reason why people are
hardcore collectors is because you get a
little hit of dopamine every time you
get that thing that's true my mom was a
compulsive shopper and part of the
reason why is because it was one of the
only ways she felt like she could
succeed dopamine is this incredible
drug bro like
we need it evolutionarily the reason it
is both it is the reward and
encouragement drug in our life so if we
don't have dopamine we don't continue to
go like
try and challenge and you know it was
essentially i i'm and again i'm not the
scientist here but from the things that
i've read and listened to you know
evolutionarily we needed it to in order
to push us to go run miles and miles and
miles and miles and miles and miles to
go find prey somewhere out there that
hopefully wouldn't kill us while we
tried to kill it and then bring it miles
and miles and miles and miles home and
then find a new location and a new
location and a new place to set up camp
without dopamine we wouldn't get it
because dopamine
so i'm going to go and you could be and
you could be deficient surely deficient
on dopamine and a lot of people are
deficient in dopamine that don't know
that they're deficient yes yes because
because essentially dopamine has
diminishing returns like almost every
you know thing every drug every every
hormone if you if you're hitting it too
hard it eventually stops doing the thing
you want it's you know at its highest
level so
then what happens is and i think this
happens starting early on as a child and
also moving up to the northwest when i
was in middle school which was that was
the first probably clinical depression i
ever had because i went from being in
sunny southern california and a cali kid
and up to seattle when i was this new
kid and super nerdy and all the kids
like did not like me and
oh man and i and and it was like the
seasonal depression stuff like for four
years i was living in this gray dreary
man it was hard but again i didn't
recognize norden my parents because they
weren't tuned in enough that i was
clinically depressed at that point like
hardcore clinically depressed and i was
also in this very traumatic household
when my mom and step dad fought like
cats and dogs
so much dysfunction and so i would go to
these video games or rollerblading oh my
god i was a huge rollerblader when i was
in middle school no wonder all the kids
loved me and um and so but i would do
these things and these would give me my
dopamine and i was very addicted to
these things i had to go and do these
things well
eventually what happens and you don't
know it is that you need more and more
and more and more and more and more and
more and more and more just to get the
same kind of feeling that you started
with
and eventually that you have to pay the
piper on that so this is one of the
coolest things i've learned
dopamine
kind of works
on like in this
lever in our mind if you will like a
seesaw okay right and it's this pleasure
pain seesaw now pain by the way is not
just physical pain it's really just kind
of any dir any time you're under duress
creative duress mental duress physical
duress like if you're trying to solve a
problem that can be the pain side of of
the lever if you're in physical pain
that can be the painstaking lever things
like that
and the other side is pleasure it's the
dopamines and serotonins and think well
specifically dopamine
and and it's this feel good it's a
reward so when you go work hard your
body then feels good so like runner's
high going to the gym and lifting
weights you're really putting your body
through it and you feel great on the
other side of it right i need dopamine
right well so check it out i need
dopamine ryan so check it out
so
the way this lever
this this this back and forth works is
when you push down on one side of that
you push down and you push down like
let's say you're pushing down on the
pain side so you're working out of the
gym real hard
and you're doing it you're you're run
five miles and then all of a sudden now
you stopped you now you now you you're
on your the duress is over and now your
body then flips to the other side
corrects for how much it was pushed down
on this side and then corrects over on
that side for whatever amount and now
you get the pleasure out of it now the
dopamine gets released into your body
but here's the trick
if you push down on the fun side if
you're pushing down on to get the
dopamine so you're just playing video
games i mean not that you not you're not
some director
no no but yeah you start you start oh
well you you
you have to pay the piper on the other
side if you're if you're just drinking
or just doing drugs or you're doing sex
or anything that is not essentially
earning the dopamine earning the reward
you're just giving yourself the reward
you're just playing video games and
giving yourself the reward you're just
doing that
that still has to balance back the other
way and people don't know that that's
why
you feel
horrible the next day after you've gone
out partying too hard or or when you've
gone and had sex with somebody and it
didn't was soulless and it didn't mean
anything like oh my you know what why do
i feel so horrible about this well part
of it is that i mean part of it is a
spiritual thing but also part of it is
your body was like didn't earn it
you didn't earn it right you know it's
it's it's really interesting so so then
if you'd end up doing that a lot and
that dude and i've self-medicated in so
many ways for so long in my life i still
do in ways you know i mean it's
but i think i i'm at a much healthier
place in my life and again i feel very
good about who i am you're aware more
aware far more awake absolutely but
the concept is
crazy and it's real and i think that if
we can understand that better we can
love ourselves better and understand
that hey don't go after the cheap
dopamine go after the good stuff go and
go and take care of your body go take
care of your mind take care of your
heart
take care of your soul take care of each
other
those those things are all a little
accomplishment waking up in the morning
you know like what um
they always say you know first thing in
the morning you want to wake up and make
your bed
it's not to have a cleaner room it's
because you get your first you're first
hitting it don't have accomplishment
it's a you get your first little hit of
dopamine and you want that because it's
it's a it's kind of like a there's a
momentum to it the more dopamine you can
kick in earned in these little
accomplishments you know you know like
i'm so envious of people that are always
so like they wake up in the morning and
they are so on it and they're like they
got a checklist
and you can sense it they are happier
people i mean some of them are
incredibly like anal or whatever
but
that aside
for to be able to be like so into
accomplishing the things that you want
to go and accomplish and you earn them
and
you definitely feel more and also it
makes you feel like you can accomplish
more that's part of the encouragement
part of dopamine you get the reward but
it also encourages you and more
and more you can do more this is why you
could keep running from one mile to two
miles to three miles ryan's nodding yeah
he's like yeah yeah dude it's real it's
real write this down i need more
dumbbells i need to make my bed yeah
it's all important stuff man i know i
started making my bed over the pandemic
that helped so
much just a little little expensive
little accomplishments you know this is
it's amazing how when i talk to you
almost so i'm like oh my god we're
we've talked for an hour and it doesn't
even feel like have we not talked for an
hour i don't know yeah an hour and five
minutes we've talked already and i want
to listen i i always learn so much from
you i really do you're just so open and
giving and i feel like i want to have
you on the show
every year every year you have to come
on because you're so you know what
happened
you help people
you're you're genuinely a good guy
you're genuinely a good guy and i think
you've worked hard on yourself and i'm
so glad that you love yourself i'm
trying
daily practice daily practice
but you got it by the way and just
going back to that for a second
you know
when you had asked
why you loved yourself
of course the the thing that we go to
the most is well we think about
oftentimes like these are things i like
about myself or
what i've accomplished or you know
whatever those types of things like i'm
good at these things
try to i think this is important try to
forget all that
and and understand what it means to love
yourself without all that
because there are no qualifiers
imagine radically loving yourself and
other people so much that you don't even
need the qualifier of well i like this
about me or i did this well or whatever
because that still
does not stand in the way of you being
infinitely lovable
we like it do you understand i do okay
uh this is called [ __ ] talking with zach
levi these are a couple of questions you
could uh spit fire fast oh are we going
to the end of the podcast well not
necessarily
i mean sort of yes oh man our episodes
are an hour we like you know we don't
there's some people that there's some
people that have three hours and i'm
just like i can't get to the meaning of
life here but no rosie's got other
things to do no but i think we are
talking about the meaning of life don't
you
i think that's exactly what we're
talking about for sure for sure lisa h
favorite beverage
favorite bev i mean to be perfectly
honest at this point in my life as it
probably should be water i guess i mean
but if we're talking about other than
water if we're trying to like uh like um
alcoholic beverage tequila soda
a reposado a nice restaurant gives you
boners too keeps boners
yeah tequila's good for boners i think
anyway was unaware of that raj describe
your 2021 in song lyrics
that could be really fun oh man um
see here's part of the problem i no no
part of the problem is that
i'm one of those guys who always knows
the melody but
almost never knows all the lyrics like i
know tell me tell me though and i'll see
if i can help you no i don't well for i
don't know like he's asking for lyrics
mine would be have you never been
mellow have you never tried
what song is that it's uh olivia newton
john olivia newton john oh man she's oh
okay i got one um
it's the end of the world as we know it
and i feel fine
yeah something like amy b have you ever
had a paranormal supernatural anomalous
anomalous experience if so what did you
experience hmm
um
i don't know
paranormal
paranormal experience
supernatural yeah anomalous anomalous is
that what the word is anomalous well i
do feel like i might have seen some kind
of ufo once i think i did too yeah yeah
yeah
everybody might oh yeah
the government's always like oh we were
testing rockets and we go oh it was just
rockets but really it was all aliens the
whole time it's snowing there's so many
new documents coming out
but like the government's like yeah so
yeah they're we don't even get me
started we don't know what to do don't
get me started on this there's so much
[ __ ] coming out we can talk about that's
amazing bob k what breed of dog best
describes you
um
well i'd like to save the breed of my
dog which is like a
queensland healer like a blue healer but
that's probably not true i don't know
most people would associate me more to
like a
golden retriever or something i could
see your lovable gold happy happy and
bad people would consider me a girl
happy and bouncy leah asks favorite
thing about living in texas and least
favorite thing
uh
a favorite thing i mean i don't know
it's super groovy i mean particularly
austin i just think it's a group i live
out just outside of town but i still get
into austin a good bit and i just i love
my friends there i love the community
there i love the art scene and the vibe
and the food and
very very big on austin um and all that
jazz
the thing i would probably say i i i
least like is just when the weather is
not cooperating you know and sometimes
that can be because it's like super hot
sometimes it's because it's super cold
sometimes it's because it's like super
raining or you know rainy or windy or
it's certainly not southern like
probably other than my friends and
family and community that i had to leave
behind here in la
uh the only thing i really miss is the
weather what you know everything else
you guys can have that could happen uh
leanne says not a question but a comment
thank you so much for all you do for
promoting mental health awareness really
appreciate all you do amen always
michelle k what can you do today that
you were not capable of a year ago or
maybe two years ago
what's different what are you capable of
doing now well i'm capable of throwing a
better football
which i appreciate good um
but you know yeah i mean i don't know
going back to literally what we were
talking about before i am more capable
of loving myself now than i was a year
ago and yes and therefore two years ago
or or you know three or four whatever i
think every again you know we're every
day we're the only person we're
competing with is ourselves from
yesterday that's it if we're competing
with anyone or anything else then we've
lost the plot you're just trying to keep
daily gradually granularly working on
yourself and loving yourself more and
every single moment where you would
normally
you do a thing and you're embarrassed or
you're ashamed or all just stop and go
hey you know what
yes i need to learn from this yes this i
should probably not do this thing
but i understand that i'm this is a re
this is a manifestation of unhealed [ __ ]
in my life amen
and that doesn't excuse it it but it can
give you grace with yourself it can give
you patience with yourself and you can
do it in that moment one two three four
five mil robin's is that who she's got
the five second rule whatever count to
five and in that moment say
love yourself more
love yourself more than what you're than
what you're about to do right now and
remind yourself
yeah so i do i that's i thought i'm
better i love it
um
this is a quick question i want to know
you know there's been so many revivals
of like you know buffy or whatever
they're doing going back and doing like
six episodes of party down and this and
that uh reno nine one do you think if
they ever asked you to do a chuck like
kind of like a little five episode thing
or something you'd consider it
what well they're talking to you about
it you're smiling so
so i've been trying to make a chuck
movie
since before we even finished the show
like i i i was always like you know for
almost no money budget and no time we
were basically making a mini action
movie every week anyway right and so if
we had like a little more budget and a
little more time we could make i think
some really killer little truck movies
you know and put them online whatever
the heck i've been literally trying to
do this since 2012
and uh
dude i feel like the time is is nearly
it's nigh yeah i i've had some very
good promising conversations with
uh producers well with with the creators
josh schwartz and chris fedak and we had
a really lovely get-together and catch
up and you know
i a few well during the pandemic we did
we did a chuck reunion um
zoom you know uh a deal and um
it was so great i mean i think it was a
great reminder for everybody like just
how special and magical our little
family was and and and everyone was just
like right back into it it was it was
really great and uh and and i think josh
and and chris you know and they've built
entire empires for themselves now and it
just and the time is i think is good so
hopefully i don't know we'll see i for
all the chuck fans who are listening to
this right now this is not well maybe
i'll i don't know i don't know if this
is a special announcement yeah i don't
know if this is an official announcement
or not but i will tell you that for all
of you have been patient thank you for
your patience i have not stopped trying
and i will not stop trying i've joked
that i will you know even if i'm a
geriatric chuck we're going to do it one
day
but um but yeah man i think i think
we're close to making something happen
which i'm super excited about and and i
think it works perfect because now you
know like it's a warner brothers show
it's
it's owned by warner brothers and um
you know and i think that uh
you know with all the streamers now and
you know
hbo max i mean you know like
that
we could easily just start making some
movies and putting them there and i want
to roll yeah i want some role in that oh
we'll work on that we'll work on that
dude uh lastly i mean i know this is
kind of a dark subject but i know you
lost your mom in 2015 to cancer yeah and
i know it's been no no no not to cancer
no no also also i appreciate that but
not dark it's not dark i i i just want
to know how you
how you deal with that because there was
a lot of dysfunction and i know you
loved your mother and i know there was a
lot of
it was tough but uh do you feel like you
still think about it do you still deal
with it is it something that you'll
always deal with or you you pretty you
feel pretty good about it no
no i i i don't know man i mean look
in the midst of all of the
insanity that that was my relationship
with my mom you know for the last you
know 13 years or whatever we didn't have
a relationship i i attempted to help her
in as many ways as i could without
enabling as as much as possible which is
very difficult sometimes you know like
i mean you know at one point she was she
was basically going to go to jail or go
to uh or be homeless and you know like
you don't know what to do because your
mother is very mentally unhealthy very
mentally and emotionally very unhealthy
and
unless somebody like that sees
like a really hard like hits a real wall
are they ever going to recognize that
they need help and so you put in this
weird gambit really it's like well
i don't want my mom to be homeless but i
also don't want her to keep being the
thing that would make her homeless like
in her in her unwellness
so we we danced for you know 13 years of
trying to do the best i was doing the
best i could
um
you know but uh
in that time and even after you know
when she died i wept for three days
super hard and then i stopped and i
didn't cry anymore after that until i
went to therapy
uh you know not two two years after that
thinking i had dealt with that all the
time like i didn't even when my mom was
still alive i would be like you know i
don't i don't hate my mom i don't i
don't hold anything against my mom well
i was suppressing so much [ __ ] so much
[ __ ] so i i you know if you're not
metabolizing that then you think you've
dealt with it because you've done some
mental gymnastics to convince yourself
that you have but you have to go feel
that stuff emotionally you got to
actually feel it and so it wasn't until
i went to therapy and i you know was in
connecticut those three weeks that
totally saved my life really and one of
my assignments was write a letter to
your mom and your dad and i you know it
took me 10 minutes just to start i was
crying so hard when i first started to
write this i couldn't ten minutes went
by and i couldn't every time the pen
would go to paper i'd be like okay
i mean it was gnarl sparkly
and then um you know and then finally i
started writing it and the whole front
of this piece of paper was
[ __ ] like i can't believe you did all
these things to me and the girl my
sisters and why did you do this and you
did this and you did that and yeah
you're just really kind of venting and
getting stuff out and i flipped the page
and this was not even an intentional
thing i was thinking to do or whatever
but i flipped the page and literally
something just flipped in my mind and
all of a sudden it was empathy that
poured out and i was like
oh buddy
it was just like
but i know i know that all you did all
these things because
they were done to you because you were
abused as a girl you were abused as a
kid
and i said you know i just recognized
like and that's why i think it's so
important
we have to
we have to look at each other
our parents are the rest of our family
our friends society
our worst enemies the people that you
would see as the most evil in the world
and you have to see
the child in them
we have to stop and look at the child in
that person that was abused they got
different programming they came from a
different world
and go okay you're not evil
you are just you can't you this your
journey was entirely different and maybe
in your journey you were so [ __ ] up
you were so abused you were taught that
killing people is good or hurting people
or stealing from people
that's why people do these things
it's not because they're monsters it's
not because they're evil it's because
they were once abused themselves so all
of a sudden that was like the whole
second half of this letter forgiveness
forgiveness forgiveness
radical radical love radical acceptance
radical radical forgiveness man it's not
necessary for all of us for this world
right now i agree with you 100 and thank
you for being so open about that i mean
it's beautiful it's beautiful i i went
through the same thing with uh i did a
little emdr
about connecticut and i remember saying
i'm fine i'm fine and every day she was
like yeah i don't think you're i don't
think we're not gonna do this today yeah
okay when are we gonna do it next day
now we're not gonna do this and then one
day i just had this this thought i go i
go oh yeah this happened blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah
i'm gonna give let's talk about we're
gonna do the emdr right now and i go
whoa whoa whoa and we started doing it
and i started
crying
hysterically like oh my god what's
happening it's uncontrollable and it's
coming out it's like why did you do this
why did you do this why was this why why
couldn't you be more patient why
couldn't you be and all of a sudden
i just said
but i forgive them
and i just started crying i don't even
know why i said it but subconsciously i
did it came out like you just said in
the writing i forgave yeah and that
there's something to be said about that
that that feels good that you're like
you did the best you could i forgive you
i'm not giving them you know any um
100 but i but i do think that
in order to get to actual true
forgiveness because i think a lot of us
think we're practicing forgiveness with
a lot of people
including ourselves and we might be on
some level
but
there's still something there's still
some
judgment
in us of but they did this to me you
know they it
you know what i mean and the only way to
actually fully get rid of all that in
you which is this poison that we drink
hoping the other person in order to get
rid of all of it
you've got to radically accept it there
is no i ca i i'm not an expert in this
i've done a lot of therapy i've read a
lot of things and listened to a lot of
people that are way smarter than me and
i the only thing that i can point to
that can get us there and this is with
ourselves with our families with with
our country right now the polarization
the the politicization of everything
that's going on every way that we keep
getting ripped asunder as human beings
and as a society we have got to look at
other people and radically accept them
and where they came from
and and that's not just forgiving them i
think a lot of people are like well i'll
forgive you for doing that thing but
you're still an [ __ ] you know right
right and again they might be an [ __ ]
but for you to be that's just for you to
recognize that they're doing [ __ ]
stuff and have boundaries but to sit and
have this yeah but that [ __ ] the way
we all roll our eyes and look down our
nose and all these things the sarcasms
that we use with each other look at the
[ __ ] news man like journalists don't
even report news anymore all they are
are opinion machines there are three
machines
on all sides it doesn't matter what the
political spectrum is on all sides of it
they're just sniping each other left and
right and there's so much disdain there
is so much hubris there it makes me sad
it makes me sick to my stomach that this
is the way that we're being led as
people this is this is the narrative
that's being spewed forth the people's
minds continue to be
essentially more programmed by it's more
hate and it's more fear instead of
looking across the island saying listen
i completely disagree with you but i
know that you're still
i mean whether you believe in god or not
you're a creation of i i would say child
of god it doesn't matter who you are
you're a you are as a if you were alive
you're an extension of god
and that's that should be valued it
should be valued we should value people
on that alone anyway
i love you i love you too this is this
has been fantastic and this is by the
way just so you know this is probably
the longest podcast i've done in a while
i never do more than like 55 minutes an
hour right and i ca i can tell you
forever no you you take me i am so
moonlight graham i i i love you have you
thought about the lyrics finally of the
song yeah it's the end of the world yes
we know it do you do that's the one
you're going to do i feel fine and you
feel funny and i feel fine and i feel
funny right now
thumbs up thumbs up thumbs up from me
zach levi you're an extraordinary human
being a great man a good friend great
friend and uh you're always there you're
always there and i appreciate you coming
on again bless you man i receive all of
that i echo it right back at you thank
you for having such an incredible forum
for people like myself to come on and
talk about [ __ ] that we think is
important
man he got emotional didn't he you did
did you get emotional when you're
watching a little bit i mean it's hard
not to
it's hard it is man especially when
you're in the room and you're
interviewing him and he starts talking
about this and you could see his eyes
well up
and
i got emotional i got a little emotional
i tried to hide and try to be a
professional but
i really commend commend zach for
opening up like that
you know it's uh
he's a sweet guy and if you came here
again for zach levi and you like the
podcast i hope you'll stick around and
just come to listen to me talk to people
and uh watch people open up and and i
think it helps
humanity i think it helps
you know when when guests open up or
they say i always learn something from
them there's only you know you'll get
something sam you know as long as they
open up and usually they do everybody
you know
has something going on in their lives
we've all faced adversity so
uh thanks for tuning in again the at
inside of you podcast on instagram and
facebook follow us and then in twitter
at insideipod go to the inside of you
online store if you want awesome merch
sunspin.com if you want merch and you
want to zoom with me
we're going to do a stage show january
29th
january 29th at 2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific
standard time please get tickets and
listen to the band we're gonna play live
virtually it's our first show in a
couple months we're really excited
and uh awesome so i'm gonna read the top
tier patrons you ready for this these
are go to if you want to become a patron
go to patreon.com inside of you uh i
love these guys they really support the
podcast nancy d leah sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e bryan h nico p jerry w
robert b jason w kristen k emilia o
allison l raj c emily s cjp jennifer n
stacy l gen s jamal f janelle b mike e
eldon sopremo
el don sopremo he uh on a zoom he puked
when i was talking to him it was
beautiful crazy guys i love dan 99 more
ramirez san diego m chad w yeah he's
going to be a lawyer too so instead of
taking the bar he's going to take the
barf
right dan we made that joke together yes
i love him san diego m chad w liam p
janine r
maya p matty s belinda and chris h dave
h spider-man chase sheila g brad d ray h
lillian a michelle k talia m betsy d
laura l chad l rochelle nathan e marion
meg k janelle p dan n big stevie w angel
m rhiannon c corey k super sam coleman g
dev next deb
deb nixon al at the lordy play he'd play
at the uh uh who's the band
the palladium
dev nixon next tuesday night at the
palladium 8 p.m get your tickets now
palladium dev nixon
uh michelle a jeremy c sebastian k
gavinator david c
john b brandy d yvore camille asked the
c joey m willie f christina e adelaide
in omari lena n eugene and leah i got to
meet all these guys we did a big zoom
with all the uh patrons the top tier
patrons and i got to see a lot of faces
it was really nice i liked it chris
chris p nikki g corey patricia m maria
ann heather l jake b bobbitt ed a
eddie
what's up bad eh how are you mate oh
it's ed in the day
at a yeah yeah guys thank you for
listening thank you for supporting the
podcast and uh we got another great
podcast coming up episode next week
thank you to jason thank you jason
nelkin our editor who sat in for ryan
today great job great to be here great
to see you love it great to fart in
front of you earlier love it um thank
you ryan my wonderful engineer
and thank you bryce our producer
thank you cumulus agnes catrin theresa
kelly
you guys all rock i love you and i
appreciate you if you're listening if
you're listening to the podcast
but uh thank you everyone for listening
and uh be good to yourself if you have
anxiety if you have [ __ ] that you're
dealing with talk to someone man get
some help i mean better help brian goes
to better help i don't know
jason do you go to therapy i don't but i
need to you will you'll go to therapy
everybody should everybody should we
need to talk our [ __ ] out yeah check up
on your body check up on your brain yeah
yeah betterhelp.com
betterhelp.com yeah is that better
comment i think you put the code word in
inside they're not even are they a
sponsor on this episode i don't know but
i'm giving them credit because i like
these guys yeah shout out better hope
why not better help they're they're
rocking um all right michael rosenbaum
from the hollywood hills in california
jason elkin also from the hollywood
hills in california wave to the camera
jason
guys thank you for allowing me to be
inside each and every one of you until
next week be good to yourselves i'll try
to be good to myself jason be good to
yourself i will good
[Music]